Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin heute die Stabinärsin hier tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen die Anamnese gespürt fühlen.
Sie sind damit verstanden. Ja, verdoppte. Das machen wir gerne.
Mein Name ist Paul Breitner.
Ich habe Sie mit Ihrem Nachname gestabiert.
Ja, ich habe Sie mit Britannien.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich war mal 1,80 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich habe abgenommen. Ich habe heute gewogen, 68 kg.
68 kg? Sie sind abgenommen.
Ja, fast 10 kg.
10 kg?
Ja.
In kurzer Zeit?
Ja, in den letzten 2-3 Monaten.
Was fühlst du uns heute?
Frau Doktor, ich habe verschiedene Beschwerden.
Ich habe seit ungefähr 3 Wochen Rückenschmerzen.
Ich habe auch wenig Appetit gehabt, in den letzten Wochen und auch, wie ich schon sagte, Gewicht abgenommen.
Das Problem, warum ich heute zu Ihnen komme, ist, dass ich gemerkt habe, dass ich gelb bin.
Ich habe eine Gelbsucht.
Ich habe den Haushaltsabkommen gesagt, ich muss sofort ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Ja, Sie sind das sehr gut.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Beschwerden am Anfang fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit 3 Wochen diese Rückenschmerzen haben.
Ist die Beschwerden langsam?
Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden. Können Sie die wiederholen?
Sind diese Rückenschmerzen plötzlich begonnen oder langsam?
Ich würde sagen, so langsam.
Langsam.
Ich bemerke, dass diese Beschwerden verursachen.
Was die Beschwerden verursachen?
Wir haben gesagt, dass sich die Energien nicht erwegen, dass die Rückenschmerzen meistens verursachen können.
Ist das immer da oder kommt und ist zurück ein Schmal?
Eigentlich immer da, aber es ist unterschiedlich von der Intensität.
Es wird mal weh, mal weniger, aber es ist eigentlich immer da.
Ich nehme regelmäßig Schmerzmedikamente.
Welche Schmerzmedikamente haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich nehme Ibuprofen ein.
Wie viele Schmerzen?
3 Mal am Tag.
Hilft es genügend oder kommt die Schmerzen zurück?
Es hilft, aber die Schmerzen gehen nicht ganz weg damit.
Wie stark ist die Schmerzmedikante auf einer Schmerzmedikante?
Wobei 1 ist die leichte und 10 ist eine starke Schmerzmedikante.
Ich würde sagen, 4, 5.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Position oder eine Verparposition oder Bewegung,
die diese Beschwerden verschlechtert?
Ich kann nicht sagen, ich glaube nicht.
Sie liegen, schlafen?
Im Liegen vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr.
Ich kann es aber nicht sagen, das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Brauchen Sie mehr Kiste als vorher, um zu schlafen?
Nein, also schlafen kann ich normal.
Okay, haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Direkt Bauchschmerzen kann ich nicht sagen.
Der Bauch ist nicht so wie früher, kann man sagen.
Schmerzen direkt? Nein.
Was meine Sie damit?
Unangenehmes Gefühl im Bauch.
Es fühlt sich nicht wie früher an.
Wie Druck?
Vielleicht Druck, aber nicht Schmerz, kann ich nicht sagen,
dass es Schmerzen im Bauch sind.
Ist Ihnen übel? Ja, das ist ein Problem,
weswegen ich nicht viel essen kann.
Seit wann haben Sie Übelkeit?
Seit drei Wochen.
Haben Sie einbrochen?
Nein, erbrechen musste ich bisher noch nicht.
Hatten Sie diese Bechwerden einmal oder haben Sie diese Bechwerde schon einmal?
Welche meinen Sie, meinen Sie Rückenbeschwerden?
Ja.
Die hatte ich früher nicht, nein.
Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen, wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt eigentlich keine solche richtigen.
Wie können Sie die Schmerzen steckend, krampfartig,
oder dumpf rückisch schmerzen und Bauchschmerzen auch?
Also die Rückenschmerzen sind dumpf.
Bauchschmerzen, wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt keine.
Keine, aber angenehmes Gefühl.
Aufstosen, wie oft?
Aufstosen habe ich jetzt kein Problem.
Kein Problem.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Der ist nicht mehr so regelmäßig wie früher.
Ja, das kann ich sagen.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Früher musste ich, habe ich regelmäßig jeden Tag morgens Stuhlern gehabt.
Jetzt habe ich manchmal ein paar Tage keinen Stuhlgang.
Dann habe ich dann einen Tag, wo ich mal zweimal auf Toilette gehen muss.
Das ist unregelmäßig geworden.
Unregelmäßig?
3 Wochen bestehend, oder?
Schon ein bisschen länger mit dem Stuhl.
länger, 1 Jahr, 6 Monate?
Also ungefähr 3-4 Monate, seitdem ich diese, ich hatte auch eine Trombose gehabt,
da war ich auch im Krankenhaus gewesen, bei einem,
und habe ich Medikamenten, ich dachte, das kommt von den neuen Medikamenten vielleicht.
Vor 4 Monaten habe ich im linken Bein eine Trombose gehabt,
da war ich das Bein dick und rot, dann hat der Hausarzt mich auch als Krankenhaus geschickt
und da ist eine Trombose festgestellt worden.
Und waren Sie schon Medikamenten behandelt?
Ja, da habe ich das Blutverdünne bekommen, die nehme ich immer noch ein.
Erinnern Sie sich die Namen?
Ja, das, was ich nehme, ist, Älikwiss, heißt das.
Nehmen Sie diese Medikamente regelmäßig?
Ja, seit der Trombose nehme ich die regelmäßig ein.
Ja, und daher, ich habe das noch mal zurück, aber ich habe noch ein paar mal Fragen über die aktuelle Beziehung.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie sich als Gelb bemerkt, Ihre Haut gelb bemerkt.
Ja, richtig.
Also, ich habe erst in den Augen gemerkt, dann hat meine Frau noch mal geguckt,
sagt, Ihre Haut ist aber auch gelb.
Ja.
Und haben Sie bei Ihrem Stuhlgang Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Kann ich jetzt so nichts sagen, Frau Lokta, nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Was meinen Sie mit Problemen? Also, ich muss halt nachts 1-2 Mal raus, aber...
Gehen Sie so oft wie Toilette, oder haben Sie Probleme beim Urinieren?
Schmerzen so?
Nein, habe ich nicht, nein, das ist normal, aber ich muss halt nachts einmal raus oder manchmal 2-mal.
Gibt es ein bestimmtes Ursache für mächtliche Wasserlassen?
Also, der Hausarzt sagt, dass die Prosta da, aber ich weiß nicht...
Ist das vergrößert, oder wissen Sie...
Ist wohl vergrößert, ja.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente gegen...
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Farbeveränderungen auf beim Wasserlassen damit?
Also, bis heute nicht ein?
Nein.
Und Herr Breitner, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Unregelmäßig, also, vielleicht mal, wenn ich irgendwie Essen gehe, oder in Gesellschaft, sonst nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen Frage manchmal, es ist verbunden mit diesen Beschwärtern, deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen, die ich für Erkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen habe.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie eine Tromboze erlitten.
Und haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Also, ich hatte vor 10 Jahren mal einen Herzenfark gehabt.
Da habe ich auch ein Stent gesetzt bekommen.
Und da habe ich auch mit dem...
Das war vor 10 Jahren ungefähr, da habe ich auch mit dem Rauchen aufgehört, weil ich hatte vorher geraucht, über 40 Jahre.
Über 40 Jahre, Sie haben geraucht, aber seit 10 Jahren rauchen Sie nicht.
Richtig, ja, habe ich aufgehört dann, ja.
Das ist sehr gut, und das finde ich sehr wertvoll.
Das möchte ich Sie sagen.
Und Sie haben Stent eingestannt und gehen Sie regelmäßig zu Konzernen?
Letzten Mal, vor etwa 2 Jahren, da war aber alles okay.
Aber Sie haben keine Bulsch, meistens, nicht?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und Sie nehmen Ellicuse für Trombozer Therapie und nehmen Sie andere Medikamente gegen...
Ja, seit dem Herzenfakt habe ich noch andere Medikamente bekommen, weil die sagten, dass der Blutdruck auch ein bisschen zu hoch ist.
Deswegen nehme ich Blutdruck-Medikamente ein, dann Medikamente gegen Cholesterin und AS100.
Und noch ein anderes Medikament, das das Name mir jetzt noch nicht anfühlt.
Ähnern Sie sich nicht, richtig?
Ja.
Und AS100, soll nehmen Sie, heißt im Fakt, 100 Gramm.
Und gegen Altheria, Hypothonia, gegen Ultropole, was nehmen Sie?
Also Rami-Pril, und dann war noch ein zweites Medikament, das habe ich aber vergessen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt, ich glaube, bisolich kann das sein, bisolich?
Aber ich habe es nicht dabei, ich muss gucken.
Okay, Rami-Pril, wie viele Medikamente?
Ja, das sind fünf Medikament, da blenden die seit zehn Jahren schon so ein.
Morgen einmal, ist wichtig?
Morgen ist eine, ja.
Okay.
Und Herr Reichner, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ich hatte mal als junger Mann eine Blindarm-Entzündung, da bin ich operiert worden, sonst nicht.
Aber, erinnern Sie, wann war das?
Da muss ich so knapp 17 Jahre, 18 Jahre alt gewesen sein, aber ich kann Sie nicht genau sagen.
Dann hatten Sie keine Operation mehr, richtig?
Sonst habe ich keine Operation, nein.
Gut, Herr Reichner, Sie haben gesagt, Sie trinken keine Alkohol und Sie haben rauchenaufgehört.
Ja.
Das ist eine mutine Frage, das müssen wir alle patienten und patienten fragen.
Nehmen wir oder haben Sie probiert einmal Drogen?
Nein, Drogen habe ich nicht mehr, das bisher.
Das ist sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Allergien gegen etwas oder Unverzweglichkeiten?
Also, ich hatte mal vor vielen Jahren mein Antibiotikum bekommen, da habe ich Hautausschlag bekommen.
Das war eine Ziline, der Haushalt, da habe ich eine Ziline Allergie.
Tablet, richtig?
Ja, Tabletten waren das, ja.
Nein, Tabletten.
Hautausschlag.
Okay, Herr Reichner, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentner.
Rentner, und was hatten Sie vorher gemacht?
Ich war Heizungsinstallateur.
Heizungsinstallateur.
Gut.
Sind Sie feiereradet?
Ja, ich bin feieradet, ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, wir leben zusammen.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind aber schon alle erwachsen, also ich habe zwei Kinder.
Aber die sind jetzt woanders.
Gut, Herr Reichner.
Erinnern Sie sich das voran?
Ich glaube, so wie wir Eltern sind nicht im Leben.
Wir leben nicht mehr, nein, mein Vater ist relativ früh gestorben.
Der hatte Darmkrebs, der ist mit ungefähr Ende 50, also Anfang 60 gestorbenen,
ein Darmkrebs.
Meine Mutter hatte auch verschiedene Krankheiten, letztlich ist sie am Schlaganfall gestorben.
Ich bin nicht sein Land.
Ja, das ist schon lange her.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Geschwister, einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Und da sind Sie gesund?
Der Bruder hat auch so ein paar Krankheiten mit Bluthochdruck und so.
Und die Schwester hatte mal Brustkrebs, ist aber jetzt wieder gesund.
Gut, mein Breitner.
Und die sind meine Fragen.
Und haben Sie etwas hinzufügen, die jetzt hier wichtig sein können?
Was meinen Sie, warum ich gelb bin?
Ich habe mal gelesen, Gelbsucht ist mit Herpatitis vergesellschaftet.
Denken Sie, dass ich eine Herpatitis habe?
Ja, es gibt so viele verständliche Krankheiten, die diese Beschwerden verursachen können.
Bei Anamnese ist es nicht immer einfach, direkt zu sagen, dass Sie die Herpatitis haben.
Aber ich habe keine Frage.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit gereist?
Ja, ich habe in der Auskland im Urlaub regelmäßig gereist.
Wann war das letzte Mal und wo?
Das letzte Mal war im Winter, dann waren wir in der dominikanischen Republik.
Karibik.
Und wie viele Monate eigentlich genau waren Sie da?
Also ich war da zwei Wochen, das war Anfang Dezember letztes Jahr.
Ungefähr vier Monate vorher?
Ungefähr, ja, vier, fünf Monate.
Und hatten Sie damals eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein.
Oder wenn Sie zurückgekommen bin?
Ja, nachdem ich zurückgekommen bin, hat ich dann diese Tombosa gehabt.
Aber keine andere Beschwerden, nicht?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Breitner, es gibt so viele Verstände mögliche, die diese Beschwerden verursachen.
Ich werde die Körper untersuchen und ein paar Blutabnehmen und ein paar Testen durchführen,
die sehr wichtig sein können.
Und ich werde das wichtig, ein Bau-Ufterschall durchzuführen.
Und wenn wir brauchen Bau-City oder manchmal brauchen wir Bau-Spiegelung.
Bau-Spiegelung, oh.
Aber nicht immer, wenn wir etwas anderes denken, dann können wir nochmal über diese Beschwerden,
diese Verfahrensprecherin.
Ja.
Aber das ist eine Vermutung und ich kann direkt jetzt nichts sagen.
Okay.
Frau Doktor, entschuldigen Sie, wenn ich nochmal frage, wenn diese Hepatitis sein sollte.
Ist sie dann ansteckend oder was meinen Sie?
Muss ich da meiner Frau was sagen oder?
Ja, das ist ansteckend.
Und meistens, Sie stecken manchmal mit Wasser oder manchmal mit sexuellen Geschätzverkehr
oder Brunnentransitionen.
Sie können in verschiedene Wege einstecken.
Okay.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, wenn wir feststellen, dass diese Hepatitis haben,
sollen wir ein paar Testen für Ihre Frau aufdurchführen.
Okay.
Und wenn ich im Krankenhaus bin, muss ich dann in so eine Isolation gehen
oder was ist da, was meinen Sie?
Nein, direkt nicht Isolation.
Ja, genau.
Und Sie machen Sie, weil das ist nicht einstecken,
stecken Sie nicht mit Luft an.
Aber es ist wichtig zu unseren Mitarbeitern sagen,
dass Sie vorsichtig sein müssen.
Okay.
Gut.
Dankeschön Frau Doktor, für die Information.
Ja, gerne.
Gut, gibt es weitere Fragen oder Kommentare oder Fragen,
die Sie gestellt hätten noch?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Kein Fieber bisher.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß?
Oder nicht gemerkt, nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Wie sehen Ihre Stürme und Ihre Üren aus?
Bisher normal, heute hat er es nicht drauf geachtet.
Haben Sie bemerkt, nach dem etwas Ernährungsbauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen hat er so keine.
Er hat nur so ein unangenehmes Gefühl im Bauch.
Aber kann er nicht sagen, ob er es mit Essen zu tun hat.
Also eher nicht.
Er weiß es nicht genau.
Danke.
Haben Sie Yukraeus?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Könnten Sie bitte sagen,
wo genau diese Schmerzen lokalisiert sind im Rücken?
Also untere Brustwebelsäule, Oberarrettenwebelsäule.
Und strahlen Sie irgendwohin aus?
Ja, diese sind zur Seite hin,
nach beiden Seiten, in die Flanken, bei Zeitz.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestärkt.
Ich denke, es ist ein bisschen unerwartet.
Ich habe heute einen Patienten,
nämlich Paul Breitner,
70-jähriger Patient.
Ich würde gerne mit ihnen
mit der Erfindung
ein paar Mal überlegen.
Ich würde gerne mit ihnen
mit der Erfindung überlegen.
diese Patienten sprechen.
Wie diese Patienten vorstellen haben Sie seit?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Ja, Paul Breitner,
ein 70-jähriger Patient,
stellte sich bei uns heute wegen
seit drei Wochen bestätigende,
langsam aufgetretene Rückenschmerzen.
Erstmalig, langsam aufgetretene Rückenschmerzen.
So wie Paul Breitner,
Rückenschmerzen,
so wie Inappetanz
und Gewichtabnahme vor.
Der Patient, außerhalb
gab der Patient an,
dass er seit drei Wochen
Erbühne, Emesis habe,
deswegen ist er
keine Essenesse.
Er hat die Schmerzentstehung
vier bis fünf mit zehn
auf einer Schmerzkala gegeben.
Er habe Bauchschmerzen,
seit zwei bis drei Wochen
auch Bauchschmerzen,
nicht eigentlich Bauchschmerzen,
ein unangenehmes Gefühl
im Abdürmen, wie Durupgefühl.
Aber er hat nicht genau Schmerzen.
Und ihre Stuhlgang war
seit zwei bis drei Monaten
unregelmäßig gewesen.
Und der Patient bemerkt,
dass er
leider angerüstet.
Und ihre Augen,
die er in der Stuhlung hatte,
und ihre Augen gelb sein.
Und auch ihre Freunde
ihnen gesagt, dass ihre Haut gelb sein.
Er habe keine Probleme
beim Wasser lassen.
Und bis auf
oben genannte
Beschwerden, Inappetanz und Übelkeit
und Inappetanz und Emesis
hat er keine
andere vegetative Beschwerden.
Und er habe
für vier Monate
eine Tromboze in Irland-Lincoln-Byn
erlitten.
Und es ist
Medikamentös behandelt.
Und er nahe mir gegen diese Beschwerden
und die Erlitten- und Schmerzen.
Und für zehn Jahre habe er
ein Herz-Myocard-Impfark
erlitten und schmerzend bekommen.
Und deswegen nehmen er
100 mg.
Und er lernt
Artillerhipotonin und Hypocholestronomie.
Hypocholestronomie.
Und er lernt
Artillerhipotonin und
Nehme-Ramitpril
5 mg.
Und er lernt
Hypocholestronomie.
Medikamenten.
Er lernt
Artillerhipotonin und Nehme-Ramitpril
5 mg.
Er trinkt keine Alkohol.
Aber er habe vor
vier Jahren geraucht bis zum
Medikament-Impfark.
So heißt er, er rauchte nicht seit
10 Jahren.
Und er habe Allergie gegen Penicillin, die sich mit
Erlangenen verheiratete.
Er war
4 Monate vorher.
Heismud-Installier.
Aber er sei jetzt
Rendner.
Er sei verheiratet.
Er war
12 Jahre alt.
45 Jahre alt.
Er war
8 Jahre alt.
14 Jahre alt.
Er war
26 Jahre alt.
Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine hepatitis NIN und als differenzialen Diagnose
kommt in Betracht ein kolanio-Karsinon und hepatosellere Karsinon in Betracht.
Ich sollte nicht die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, weil ich kolanische Massnahmen durchführen.
Körperlöhung, Untersuchung, Labor. Im Labor sollen wir ein großes Blutbild schauen und
Lebensmärkte, Nierenmärkte und hepatitis Antikörpern, Antihepatitis C und A, Antikörpern feststellt.
Hier soll man auch eine EKG durchführen und einen Röntgen Torax durchführen. Aber Abdominalität
und Antikörpern sind auch sehr wichtig.
Kurze Frage zu Ihren Differenzialdiagnosen. Hepatitis und Scholangiocelleres Karsinon,
macht denn eine Hepatitis Rückenschmerzen oder ein Scholangiocelleres Karsinon in der Regel?
Ist das ein Leitsymptom, die Rückenschmerzen?
Ich glaube, wenn Sie sich metastasiert, wenn ein Scholangiocelleres Karsinon metastasiert,
dann haben Sie Rückenschmerzen. Aber hier, dass die Patienten nicht richtig Bauschmerzen.
Deswegen habe ich nicht sicher, ob ein Problem beim Scholangiocelleres Karsinon ist.
Also, so lange es das Karsinon kann, kann es Schmerzen machen, wenn es metastasiert.
Hepatitis macht das Rückenschmerzen normalerweise?
Sehr selten oder eher ungewöhnlich, gell?
Also, Sie denken ja richtigerweise an einen Malignom bei den Patienten. Warum?
Welche an einem nähsten Angaben lassen Sie diese Vermutung nachgehen?
Weil er hat eine Bilsemptome, nicht eine wichtige Bilsemptome.
Er hat keine Flieber, keine nötige Wasserlöse nachschweißt.
Aber er hat zu viel in letzter Zeit abgenommen.
Genau, das ist für los.
Und er hat immerhin ständig Schmerzen.
Und er soll dreimal täglich Ibuprofen abnehmen, aber jedoch die Schmerzen zurückkommen.
Okay.
Was gibt es denn noch für Informationen aus einer Nese, die in Richtung Malignom deuten könnten?
Denken Sie mal an seine Begleiterkrankung oder Begleitsprobleme in den letzten Monaten?
Ja, er hat ein beiden Stromwose erlitten.
Es gibt manche Lungenkarcinomen, die sich mit Symptomen wie Tromose auftreten.
So heißt Bromsch, Lungen, Adenocarcinoma können.
Welches Karcinom macht das noch häufiger als Lungenkarcinoma, Tromboseneigung?
Ein Karcinom, das zunehmend auftritt bei solchen älteren Patienten, häufiger als höchstlangehörigstehleres Karcinom.
Leber oder beim Lungen?
Ein Karcinom, das mit einer erhöhten Trombose-Neigung einhergeht.
Kapitosellei-Karcinom?
Das ist eher selten.
Was gibt es noch?
Hematologisches Karcinom können.
Es gibt es auch mal, aber es ist eher selten.
Der Klassiker für Panseemintrombosen ist das Pankeaskarcinom.
Passen dazu auch die Rückenschmerzen zum Pankeaskarcinom?
Ja, wo die Schmerzen gehen.
Wir können denken, dass es ein Pankeaskarcinom kann sein.
Aber nicht direkt ein Bauchschmerzen, sondern auch...
Was ist denn ein häufiges Leitsymptom von Pankeaskarcinom, wenn es fortgeschritten ist?
Kehwichtabnahme, Schmerzen...
Rückenschmerzen, ja?
Ein klassischerweise Gürtelförmige Rückenschmerzen.
Ein klassischer, leichtend vom Spätfolge eines Pankeaskarcinoms.
Was sind denn Frühzeichen manchmal von einem Pankeaskopfkarcinom?
Früh ist relativ, ein Anführungszeichen.
Was gibt es denn da beim Pankeaskarcinom?
Kann mal sein, ja, was noch?
Was dieser Patient jetzt auch hatte?
Diabetes.
Kann auch mal sein, richtig, ja.
Ist mir jetzt nicht mehr...
Der Iktarus, ja, kann auch mal ein Früheszeichen, ein Anführungszeichen,
eines Pankeaskopfkarcinoms sein.
Kennen Sie ein klinisches Zeichen, wie man das nennt, wenn ein Patient ein Iktarus hat
und ein schmerzlosen Iktarus, am besten dann auch mit einer großen Galenblase,
wenn man das nennt, kennen Sie dieses Zeichen, das klinische Zeichen?
Nein, dann nicht.
Anscheinend, was von Corvoisierzeichen gehört, Corvoisier,
das ist schmerzlose Iktarus mit Tastbärm, auch Galenblase.
Das ist meistens ein Zeichen von Pankeaskopfkarcinom,
der den Ducto-Schilodorus komprimiert oder einengst
der Obstoffen von den Galenwegen, schmerzlose Iktarus.
Das könnte ein Frühzeichen sein.
Wenn ein Patient schon schmerzt und auch ein Pankeaskarcinom hat,
das ist von der Anamese am wahrsteinlichsten,
dann habe ich schon gesagt, wenn er Rückenschmerzen hat,
ist das eher ein Früheszeichen oder ein schlechtes Zeichen?
Ich glaube, es ist schlechtes Zeichen.
Warum?
Ich weiß nicht.
Wie kommt es beim Pankeaskarcinom zu Rückenschmerzen?
Wo liegt das Pankeas?
Im Rücken.
Ja, nicht im Rücken.
Also vor der Wirbel soll, aber retroperitornial.
Und dann ist auch manchmal auch ein Nervengeflecht,
das mal betroffen sein kann.
Kennen Sie dieses Nervengeflecht oder diese Gefäßnervenstruktur,
die manchmal betroffen sein kann?
Was liegt denn in der Nähe vom Pankeas, welche Gefäße?
Ein Rückblick auf die Anatomie von langer Zeit.
Zum Beispiel der Tronkustioliakus,
also sagen wir mal allgemein, Gefäße, Blutgefäße,
Benamesentriger, Soperium usw.
Und wenn die, um diese Gefäße herumlaufen,
auch die meisten Nerven, die dann auch irritiert werden,
und was ist das für ein Zeichen, wenn diese Nerven irritiert sind?
Dass das schon die Gefäße infiltriert, das Pankeaskarcinom.
Und dann ist es, was kann man da nicht mehr machen,
wenn man beim Frühkarcinom macht normalerweise,
beim Pankeaskarcinom, was macht man da als Therapie,
wenn es ein frühes Karcinom ist, was kann man da machen?
Operation.
Operation. Und was kann man nicht machen,
wenn die Blutgefäße betroffen sind?
In der Regel kann man da nicht mehr operieren.
Also das Rückenschmerzen,
meistens ein Zeichen eines inoperablen Pankeaskarcinom
in den allermeisten Fällen,
also in Spätstadium,
weil es meistens die Blut- und Nerven schon infiltriert hat.
Ja.
Gut. Wie ist die Prognose beim Pankeaskarcinom?
Sei ich schlechte Prognose?
Ja.
In sechs Monaten steil ich und dann lese ich das Stadium.
Okay, sechs Monate. Sie sind Chirurgen, ha?
Nein, ich bin Chirurgen.
Okay, weil die Chirurgen haben früher immer gesagt,
wenn Patienten mit Diagnose-Pankeaskarcinom,
dann bei denen lag, dass sie leben nur noch sechs Monate.
Und das Problem war, die hatten oft recht.
Aber das ist natürlich nur ein Medial, in dem man hat.
Also es gibt auch Patienten, die mit Pankeaskarcinom
länger leben können.
Aber in der Regel ist das eine schlechte Prognose.
Gut, okay. Aber Sie haben schon gesagt,
was Sie jetzt machen wollen, also Laborwerte machen Sie natürlich.
Ich habe gesagt, dann machen Sie Ultraschall.
Wo nachgucken Sie Ultraschall bei den Patienten?
Was ist wichtig?
Wir können nicht Pankeas sehr richtig sehen,
weil es ist europäischer.
Deswegen, nach der Ultraschall sollen wir hier ein abdominales CT durchführen.
Ja, aber was können Sie dann manchmal,
also manchmal kann man Pankeas nicht gut sehen, Ultraschall,
das ist richtig, weil Luft überlagert und so weiter.
Was können Sie denn aber noch sehen, beurteilen,
damit Sie Differenzialdiagnose betreiben können?
Was können Sie sehen?
Wir können,
erweiterte Koleideokusee,
oder die Gallenwege,
die Gallenwege können Sie angucken,
und die Intrapartitionen und extrapartischen Gallenwege können Sie versuchen zu sehen.
Das ist wichtig, damit Sie Differenzialdiagnose haben.
Genau, weil wenn nämlich die Gallenwege nicht erwartet sind,
dann müssen Sie nach anderen Ursachen für die Iktaus suchen.
Man kann ja auch einen Deber schaden,
die anders, als ich gesagt habe,
für die Iktaus spielen.
Was gucken Sie dann noch nach,
wenn Sie die Pazie mit Iktaus haben,
was für Laborwerte machen Sie noch,
um zu wissen, was der Grund für den Iktaus ist?
Da gibt es so eine Unterteilung
und bestimmten Laborwerten, die man machen kann.
Was ist denn beim Iktaus erhöht im Blut?
Kann sein, ja.
Total billurubin, direkt und indirekt billurubin.
Sie können das direkt und indirekt billurubin differenziert bestimmen.
Was ist denn beim Verschluss Iktaus erhöht?
Direkt billurubin.
Was wäre, wenn es nur das indirekt billurubin erhöht wäre?
Das ist ein Hepatitis.
Könnte mal sein, ja, was noch?
Der Klassiker,
wo nur indirekt billurubin erhöht wäre,
wo nur indirekt billurubin erhöht ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel, genau.
Genau, das Labor, muss ich sagen.
Jetzt haben Sie Ultraschall gemacht
und können das Panker nicht gut beurteilen.
Also hat es ein bisschen erweiterten Doktorschiller doch,
aber noch nicht so, weil es jetzt ein Tag besteht.
Billurubin ist bei ungefähr acht.
Was machen Sie als nächstes bei den Patienten?
Wir müssen seine Verlachtstagnose haben.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ultraschall können Sie es nicht ganz klären.
Sie sehen nur, dass der duktische Loch etwas weiter ist als normal.
Vielleicht so zwei Zentimeter, aber ist nicht so massiv.
Bankrails Kopf können Sie nicht einsehen.
Bankrails Korpus können Sie auch nicht einsehen. Luftüberlagert.
Was machen Sie als nächstes?
Um die Garlin-Wage zu schauen, fragt sie.
Was machen Sie?
Das können Sie machen, ja wohl.
Aber bevor man das macht,
weil es jetzt nicht überall verfügbar ist,
vielleicht, was machen Sie als nächstes,
was in vielen Krankenhausen machbar ist.
Das kann man auch machen.
Meistens macht man dann CT-Abdomen dann, ja.
Dann können Sie auch den Panker-Organ beurteilen.
Können Sie sich noch in der Raumforderung erinnern?
Dann können Sie entscheiden, ob Sie eine RCP machen müssen.
Was ist denn das Problem bei Iktarus?
Ist das schlimm für den Patienten?
Da hat jemand gefragt nach Juckreit.
Das ist mal ein Symptom bei Hyperbilerubinämie.
Kann mal passieren, muss aber nicht.
Was ist das Problem bei Hyperbilerubinämie?
Warum ist das jetzt nicht ganz so ein unwichtiges Symptom?
Macht Juckreit, okay.
Ist schlimm, aber nicht so schlimm.
Was kann noch passieren?
Kann es irgendwie platzen, die Gallenblase?
Es kann ein Rückstau der Gallen verursachen.
Es ist ja schon, deswegen.
Was kann dann passieren?
Es kann auch eine Hepatitis-Insufficiency durchführen.
Wenn es längerer Zeit besteht, ja.
Was ist so akut bis superkut?
Was könnte es sein?
Kann auch so eine Begleitschollangitis bekommen.
Ein Bakteriellenzündung beispielsweise.
Das ist das Problem, warum man gerne diese
Gallengangsstauben beheben würde.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie einen CT gemacht.
Man sieht einen großen Pankreas-Tumor.
Der ist sowohl im Korpus als auch im Kopf.
Man sieht das alles, als auch im Kopf gewachsen ist.
Ist mit ihm umgebungsinfiltration.
Also klinisch und radiologisch inoperabel.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten jetzt?
Ja, wir sollen mit den Patienten sprechen.
Und Nachteile und Vorteile der Chemotherapie.
Ja, ja.
Die Chemotherapie in den Patienten
kann nicht so gut reilen.
Das kann man nicht behandeln.
Bevor sie eine Chemotherapie machen,
wir sollen symptomatisch Eingriffe durchführen.
So heißt, wir können ständig einsetzen.
Das ist das, was wir machen würden,
damit sie auch eine Voraussetzung haben,
überhaupt Chemotherapie machen können.
Mit Billirobien von 8 kann man meistens keine Chemotherapie machen.
Deswegen müssen sie versuchen, den Iktorus zu beheben.
Das kann man versuchen mit der endoscopischen Untersuchung
und Standeinlagen.
Haben Sie probiert, also Sie haben Gastronomie gebeten,
dass er einen Standeinlegten hat, probiert hat es nicht geschafft.
Was gibt es da noch für Möglichkeiten?
Mit Billi8 können Sie keine Chemotherapie machen.
Was können wir noch machen bei den Patienten?
Eine endoscopische Untersuchung hat nicht funktioniert leider.
Da kommt nicht dran.
Wir sollen dann variativ therapyieren.
Schmerzmedikamente.
Wir sollen meistens diese Patienten haben.
Die haben meistens pancreas insuffizielles.
Endocrine und exocrine pancreas insuffizielles.
Dann können wir die endoen, pancreas insuffizielles.
Das kann man machen, wenn das symptomatisch ist.
Aber lassen Sie dann so mit dem Billi8-Pilipin weiter in Ruhe?
Oder was machen Sie dann mit dem Iktorus?
Er hat noch Therapie.
Er würde gerne Chemotherapie machen, hat er gesagt.
Was machen Sie mit dem?
Chemotherapie.
Er will Chemotherapie machen, aber weiter bei Nikterus.
Billi8-Pilipin 8, damit kann man keine Chemo machen.
Schmerztherapie, Ernährung auf Therapie.
Ständen haben Sie alles gemacht.
Ständen haben Sie probiert, funktioniert nicht.
Endoskopisch Ständen ging nicht.
Was machen Sie noch mit dem?
Was können Sie machen?
Sie können die natürlich ins Hospice schicken.
Oder ins Epilativstation, klar.
Tipps.
Ja, genau.
Sie können nochmal versuchen, dann packst du eine pdcd.
Perkutane Transseptatische Scholangio-Trinage anlegen.
Müssen wir manchmal warten, bis die gar nicht wegen der Leber
ausreichend gestaut sind, damit sie das von außen punktieren können.
Und dann ist es so, dass manche Patienten
wieder ein normales Billi8-Pilipin bekommen.
Dann könntest du manchmal wieder Chemo-Therapie machen.
Zum Beispiel.
Gut, das reicht dabei.
Das ist sonst sehr speziell, glaube ich.
Alles klar.
Vielen Dank für die Vorstellung.
Haben andere Kollegen noch Kommentare oder Fragen?
Ich glaube, im Chat gab es Kommentare,
aber die haben, glaube ich, alle so weitest gehen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, es ist ja echt ausgehört zu zu spät.
Retropäten ja.
Ja, Tumormarker vielleicht ein Wort dazu.
Also Tumormarker kam beim Pankraskatznummer-Hözern,
C.A.199.
Was ist das Problem beim C.A.199?
Wenn es jetzt bei den Patienten hoch wäre,
dann wäre es sehr schwierig.
Nein, aber wir können als Follow-up benutzen.
Aber nicht direkt.
Was ist manchmal der Fall?
Also bei Patrimonik-DOS können Sie den C.A.199 nicht gut verwerten.
Der ist oft erhöht, auch wohnen das jetzt mal
eine Aussage über Tumormarkt.
Also bei Iqdros C.A.199 ist nicht sehr ausseilkräftig.
Welche Aussage ist kräftig?
Ja, keine.
Eine C.A.199 nicht.
Also die Tumormarker sind jetzt nicht hilfreich für eine Diagnose
und eher als Verlaufskontrolle, vielleicht.
Aber die sind auch störendfällig.
Also gerade C.A.199 bei Bilorubin, wie gesagt,
es kann mal hochgehen und runtergehen.
Also das ist jetzt nicht sehr spezifisch.
Aber wenn der Patient jetzt kein Iqdros hätte
und jetzt hatte ein C.A.199 von 5000,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß,
dass er ein Panker-Eskatznorm hat.
Entschuldigung, CT mit Medikamente oder ohne Medikamente?
Mit Kontrastmittel ist immer besser.
Da kann man auch so ein bisschen die Blutgefäße besser sehen
und auch die Lymphknoten umgebung ist immer besser.